Prof: Frost was born in
1879, I think;
Hart Crane in 1899,
representing almost another
generation from Frost.
Auden was born in 1906,
Bishop in 1911.
She's the latest,
the youngest on our syllabus
and she's almost two generations
distant from Robert Frost.
When I was a freshman at Yale
in 1976, in April,
Elizabeth Bishop came to read
at Yale.
She's, in a sense,
a part of our world in a way
that the poets that we've been
reading really aren't quite.
She was good friends with John
Hollander, Penelope Laurans,
on our faculty,
Sandy McClatchy and others.
She filled the art gallery
lecture hall – 400 people.
And this was at a moment,
interestingly,
when she was not yet at the
height of her fame.
She would become by the end of
the century a figure as
prominent, as often read and
widely read and esteemed,
as any of the poets we've been
reading, which is a remarkable
event in literary culture
because Bishop would have
seemed,
to herself and to others
through the course of most of
her career, as an interesting
poet but not as a major figure.
And surely, she was herself
uncomfortable with that kind of
stature.
She was, I think it's fair to
say, excruciated by public
occasions, including this one
that I'm referring to.
Listen to her read.
I think there are some
recordings of her on the Center
for Language Study website.
Bishop has a kind of
exaggeratedly ordinary voice,
in a sense, a very private
voice that she was willing to
put on stage but always only
uncomfortably.
So, in this particular reading,
I'm remembering she had read
for about 20 minutes and then
looked across the stage with
these 400 people in front of her
at her host,
Penelope Laurans:
"Is that enough Penny?" she
said.
And of course,
people wanted a lot more and a
lot more of her,
but she was reluctant to give
it and uncomfortable giving it.
Bishop, in a sense,
belongs to poetry after modern
poetry, poetry after modernism.
In September,
I'm going to give a lecture
course on poetry after 1950,
and we'll start with Bishop and
pay a lot more attention to her
than we have room to do in this
course.
But Bishop belongs,
too, in any history of modern
poetry and she provides,
I think, an important endpoint
to the work that we've been
doing together.
She provides,
in a sense, a kind of extension
of certain strains of modern
poetry and also at the same time
a kind of critique of them.
Bishop went to Vassar and she
was on the literary magazine
there.
In 1929, I think,
she interviewed the important
guest on the campus,
T.S. Eliot.
I would have liked to have been
in the room.
She wrote--well,
I guess what I want to
highlight is the fact that
Bishop was in college reading
Eliot and having Eliot visit
when she was really forming
herself as a writer.
She wrote a paper for one of
her courses called "Dimensions
for a Novel," and this essay
involved a reading of Eliot's
essay,
"Tradition and the Individual
Talent," which you've read and
which we've talked about.
Bishop liked it;
she was interested in it.
In her account of the way in
which she uses Eliot,
she accents certain aspects of
his ideas and downplays others.
Let me quote from that essay.
She says--this is on your
handout:
A constant process of
adjustment [and that's Eliot's
word, "adjustment"]
is going on about the
past--every ingredient dropped
into it from the present must
affect the whole.
[You remember Eliot writing
about that in "Tradition and the
Individual Talent,"
where he talks about how new
work reshapes everything that's
gone before.]
Now what Mr. Eliot says about
the sequence of works of art in
a tradition, in history [and
this is Bishop's extension of
Eliot's idea]
seems to be equally true of the
sequence of events or even of
pages or paragraphs in a
novel….
but I know of no novel that
makes use of this constant
readjustment among the members
of any sequence.
So, what Bishop's doing is
applying Eliot's idea of
sequence in tradition to the way
in which a literary work might
itself unfold;
that is, where every,
as it were, new moment in a
novel – here she's talking
about a novel – affects a kind
of readjustment of what's gone
on before.
It is, as she's imagining it,
a literary form in which there
is a kind of continual
reorientation required by both
reader and writer.
She takes over specifically
that phrase "constant
readjustment" and identifies
this as a kind of poetics,
if you will.
This is really an important
idea in modern poetry generally.
And you could look at Eliot's
own poetry in,
for example,
"Prufrock" as exemplifying
something of what Bishop is
describing,
that is, a poem that unfolds,
disclosing at every point new
principles of order and
perspective.
It's an idea that is in that
sense central to modern poetry,
but Bishop takes it and she
pushes it in her own work much
further.
She creates in her poetry a
radically relative point of view
that is adjusted to a kind of
metamorphic and decentered
world,
as she sees it – a world that
is living in change.
That phrase you might remember
from the very end of "Primitive
Like an Orb," Stevens's great,
late poem.
Bishop is, in many ways,
a Stevensian poet,
a poet of change,
constant change.
But significantly in Bishop's
imagination, as in Auden's,
there are no Stevensian giants,
no major men,
no large men reading.
The poet in Bishop's poetry
describes the world rather than
creates it.
The poet is not like God as the
poet is in Stevens.
The poet is much more like an
ordinary person,
a woman on stage in a skirt,
speaking uncomfortably,
if you like,
to a large audience in an
ordinary voice.
Her poetry is,
in fact, full of ordinary
people, and this links her to
Frost.
There are generally few,
oh, emblematic or archetypal
figures such as you find in
Yeats or in Moore's poetry or
often, for that matter,
in Auden's.
There is in Bishop really no
sublime, no Yeatsian ascent out
of "the foul rag and bone shop
of the heart."
There's no Cranian verticality,
no Icarus-like ascent of the
sky.
Instead, Bishop's poetics of
description are what I would
call a kind of horizontal
poetics that moves laterally,
that is earthbound and is
concerned with,
in a sense – this is her
primary recurrent trope –
mapping the world,
giving an account of the
earth's surface.
It's a perceptual poetics that
she's concerned with,
something she calls "geography"
or sometimes "travel."
The poem that really
inaugurates Bishop's mature
writing and that she placed
first in her first volume of
poetry,
North and South,
and that subsequently was
placed first in all collected
volumes of her poems is the poem
called "The Map."
It's a kind of preface to her
work and it's an inevitable
place to start thinking about
her.
So, let's look at it together.
A poem written in--I believe at
least begun New Year's Eve,
1933 as Bishop left college.
Maybe you seniors will write
your own "Map" next year.
She didn't collect it in a book
until 1946, which is her first
book publication;
like Stevens,
like Frost, she's slow to
gather her first poems.
The poem begins with a
marvelous, limpid clarity.
Land lies in water;
it is shadowed green.
Shadows, or are they shallows,
at its edges
showing the line of long
sea-weeded ledges
where weeds hang to the simple
blue from green.
Or does the land lean down to
lift the sea from under,
drawing it unperturbed around
itself?
Along the fine tan sandy shelf
is the land tugging at the sea
from under?
It's a deceptively declarative,
flat voice, a voice of
description.
It is interestingly impersonal
and intimate at once.
It's as if we were so close to
her she need not introduce
herself.
We are invited to look over her
shoulder with her at the map.
She doesn't,
as I say, introduce herself or
her subject really here.
She just starts.
The poem represents itself as
happening now,
as if it were recording the
mind in action,
a process, an action of
perception.
The poem was gathered first for
publication by Marianne Moore,
who was Bishop's friend and
mentor – a friendship
described in Bishop's long,
beautiful, funny memoir,
"Efforts of Affection," that I
asked you to read when we were
reading Moore;
an essay that tells you a lot
about Moore but also tells you a
lot about Bishop.
Moore, as her mentor,
gathered this and two other
poems and had it published in a
volume in which an older poet
presented a younger,
as a teacher or mentor would
present a protégé.
Moore says about Bishop's poems
a number of interesting things.
I've sampled just these
sentences on your handout.
Some authors do not muse
within themselves [but by
contrast, Bishop does];
they [they, those other
authors]
"think" --- like the
vegetable-shredder which cuts
into the life of a thing.
Miss Bishop is not one of these
frettingly intensive machines.
Yet the rational considering
quality in her work is its
strength [the rational
considering quality]
--- assisted by unwordiness,
uncontorted intentionalness
[phrases that only Marianne
Moore could have produced],
the flicker of impudence,
the natural unforced
ending.
These are important qualities
of Bishop's writing,
although to highlight them is
to risk a sort of misperception;
that is, if Bishop presents
herself as a kind of rational,
considering intelligence in
these poems,
what she very rapidly uncovers
is fantasy and the fantastic or
fabulous or metaphorical.
Just so, her poetry of
perception and description
rather than giving us a kind of
poetics of objectivity that we
might associate with Pound and
Imagism,
very quickly turns back on the
perceiving subject to ask
questions about the process of
perception itself and to
suddenly become a poetry very
much about subjectivity.
You can see this going on
already in the lines that I've
quoted here.
Bishop no sooner says one thing
than she elaborates it or
questions it.
"Shadows, or are they
shallows," she says.
She's formulated one idea,
and then she asks a question
about it, and then a further
question about that.
This is very much an image of,
a poetics of a mind in action,
a mind thinking.
That is the drama that Bishop
shares with us.
In another early statement,
this in a letter to a poet,
Donald Stanford,
she quotes a literary critic on
Baroque – that is,
seventeenth-century – prose
which she liked.
And this quotation is also on
your handout.
"Their [that is,
the writers of Baroque prose]
purpose was to portray,
not a thought,
but a mind thinking….
They knew that an idea
separated from the act of
experiencing it is not the idea
that was experienced.
The ardor of its conception in
the mind [that's my misprint]
is a necessary part of its
truth."
The ardor of the conception in
the mind is what Bishop wants.
"Ardor" – that's an important
word.
It suggests passion,
a certain amount of heat,
emotion, and heart.
In Bishop's case,
this ardor is communicated
sometimes through the
deceptively cool manner of
self-interrogation and in
particular through the
grammatical form of the
question.
Here in this very first
paragraph of her poetry,
Bishop is asking questions.
There's a kind of level of
clarity and detail in her
observations that makes what's
she's looking at interestingly
unstable and uncertain.
She turns back on it,
asks questions about it.
You could contrast Bishop's
questions with Yeats's great
rhetorical questions,
a form that we stressed in
reading "Leda and the Swan" and
other late Yeats poems.
In general, thinking about
Bishop's relationship to Yeats,
you could say that romance
quest,
which is this essential
structure that's behind all of
Yeats's poetry,
romance quest has come down in
Bishop to the act of asking
questions,
raising questions,
here in this poem and very
frequently in other Bishop poems
questions specifically about
boundaries,
about the way in which we
categorize and frame the world,
how we draw lines and separate
and connect things at the same
time.
As we do, one thing seems to
turn into another;
opposites interact,
opposites are involved.
Notice the pair of opposites
that she's stressing here.
Land and water:
these are primary categories
that her poetry centers itself
on over and over again.
Bishop is a poet of the
seashore.
There are poems throughout her
career that station themselves
on the beach,
in particular;
a place of unstable,
uncertain dynamic boundary.
You can see the same kind of
play of similarity and
difference between terms in
Bishop's poetry on a formal
level already working here in
this first stanza.
It is rhymed poetry, isn't it?
But what an interesting set of
rhymes!
Green, edges, ledges, green;
under, itself, shelf, under.
These are rhymes where it seems
as though words are a little too
close together.
They're repeated,
"green," or maybe a little too
far apart.
In the second stanza then,
the rhyme scheme gives way
entirely.
And this is like Bishop to set
up one pattern and then drop it.
The shadow of
Newfoundland lies flat and
still.
Labrador's yellow,
where the moony Eskimo
has oiled it.
We can stroke these lovely bays,
under a glass as if they were
expected to blossom,
or as if to provide a clean
cage for invisible fish.
The names of seashore towns run
out to sea,
the names of cities cross the
neighboring mountains
-- the printer here
experiencing the same excitement
as when emotion too far exceeds
its cause.
These peninsulas take the water
between thumb and finger
like women feeling for the
smoothness of yard-goods.
Then the rhyme scheme returns,
and, again, it's a peculiar one
that includes not just a rhyme
but a repetition of particular
words.
Mapped waters [she says]
are more quiet than the land
is,
lending the land their waves'
own conformation:
and Norway's hare runs south in
agitation,
profiles investigate the sea,
where land is.
Are they assigned,
or can the countries pick their
colors?
-- What suits the character or
the native waters best.
Topography displays no
favorites;
North's as near as West.
More delicate than the
historians' are the map-makers'
colors.
It's a poetry like aspects
Yeats's – no,,
like aspects of Moore's,
that presents itself with a
kind of resolute clarity and
simplicity and lucidity of
language that sometimes seems to
feel like prose.
There is a lyric power here but
it's got at through a language,
again, close to that of
ordinary life.
As Bishop observes the
boundaries that she's talking
about here – the sea and the
shore – she's also concerned
with another set of opposed
terms and ones that will follow
her throughout her poetry;
and that is the difference
between the real and
representation and the ways in
which representation,
that which is represented,
can take on a certain kind of
reality itself,
as she fancifully allows the
forms of the map to do here.
The map really becomes a world
and not only a representation of
it, and the poet plunges really
imaginatively into it--takes us
with her,
as she does,
entering the versions of life
that it suggests to her.
In that third stanza there,
though, as she returns to that
peculiar rhyme scheme,
there's a certain kind of
holding back,
a gathering of her intelligence
in reflection on the process
that she's been engaged in.
What emerges there is a kind of
key idea, the one I've already
mentioned, geography or
topography here.
Geography, topography:
they display "no favorites."
They represent a poetics that
is non-hierarchical in its
orientation and,
again, this is a link to Moore.
Bishop is interested in a point
of view that takes no sides,
except to suggest,
to insist on,
the relativity of all cognitive
categories.
"North's as near as West":
it always is,
right?
That is, it's as near to the
perceiver, whose perspective is
constantly shifting,
constantly readjusted.
I talked about perspectivism in
Auden.
Well, Bishop has a hold on the
same idea and will make it even
more central,
make it more thematically
central to her work than even
Auden.
The opposition that she ends
with is the one between the
historian and the mapmaker.
She presents herself here
clearly on the side of the
mapmaker, one whose colors –
colors of rhetoric – are more
delicate than the historian's
and on the side of the
historian;
who could we place?
Perhaps Yeats,
perhaps Pound,
perhaps Eliot;
certainly Bishop's great
contemporary,
Robert Lowell.
Bishop presents herself as
engaged in a poetics of
geography and of mapmaking that
is more delicate than that of
the historian.
In that word,
"delicacy," there is certainly
some implication of gender.
The opposition between the
mapmaker and the historian:
well, it would be too simple to
call it an opposition between
woman and man,
and yet gendered terms are
there in Bishop's language,
I think.
This poem, as I suggested,
is composed in 1933 after
Bishop has left Vassar and has
made friends with Moore who will
be a central figure in her life.
If, in some sense,
emotion might exceed its cause,
might lead Bishop to get
carried away,
there were lots of reasons why
this might be so.
Bishop grew up at first in Nova
Scotia.
She is a Canadian poet as much
as an American poet – a poet
of uncertain national identity,
you might say.
Her father died when,
I believe, she was five.
Her mother in grief went mad
and was institutionalized,
and Bishop was separated from
her, so that she grew up very
much as an orphan.
Much has been made of her
biography.
I wouldn't encourage you to
because Bishop herself treats it
as an important frame and
resonance for her poetry,
but not as a rule as its
subject.
There is, I think,
simply the important point to
be made that here is a poet who
grew up with a certain primary
sense of dislocation and
disorientation,
and an acute sense of divided
identity: biographical facts
that, in a sense,
lead us very quickly into the
ethical and cognitive problems
that are central to Bishop's
work,
and I think to this problem in
particular: how do you hold
yourself together?
It's an important one and one
that we all in various ways
struggle with.
Bishop finds various ways to
raise that question,
to figure it and explore it.
One early, amusing,
and suggestive instance is the
poem called "The Gentleman of
Shalott."
And I'd like to look at that
with you to get a little more
sense of Bishop's poetics and
some sense of her early
self-conception as a poet.
Remember the idea that she's
taken from Eliot:
she wants to imagine a kind of
writing that would include time
in it,
that would include change in
it, and in which the
organization of the whole would
be constantly subject to
readjustment;
a text that would incorporate
flux, a text that would be
determined locally rather than
by some global and general
perspective.
The, I think,
unstable orders of a poem like
"Prufrock" are important for
Bishop in that Prufrock is,
in fact, a figure behind this
one of Bishop's,
"The Gentleman of Shalott."
Bishop's character is a kind of
dandy, like Prufrock.
Bishop is also at the same time
playing with Tennyson and his
poem, "The Lady of Shalott."
A kind of gender switch has
occurred in Bishop's poem.
What does it mean?
Well, I'll leave you to ponder
it, but I think that one way to
understand her joke here – I'm
not going to write about the
lady of Shalott,
I'm going to write about the
gentleman of Shalott – one way
to understand her joke here is
to suggest that this poem is in
part about what it means for
Bishop to be a woman poet,
and it implies that that meant
for her a certain kind of gender
switch, a sex change,
and one that might introduce a
certain amount of stress,
as well as comedy.
Well let's listen to some of it.
Which eye's his eye?
Which limb lies
next the mirror?
Her joke is that the gentleman
of Shalott, like the lady of
Shalott, is fixated on a mirror,
but the mirror that is in place
here is one that,
as she'll describe it,
goes down the body,
splits this figure,
and creates a kind of divided
figure.
Which limb lies
next the mirror?
For neither is clearer
nor a different color
than the other,
nor meets a stranger
in this arrangement
of leg and leg and
arm and so on.
To his mind
it's the indication
of a mirrored reflection
somewhere along the line
of what we call the spine.
He felt in modesty
his person was
half looking-glass,
for why should he
be doubled?
The glass must stretch
down his middle,
or rather down the edge.
But he's in doubt
as to which side's in or out
of the mirror.
There's little margin for error,
but there's no proof, either.
And if half his head's
reflected,
thought, he thinks,
might be affected.
This is poetry that presents
itself as light verse.
In that way,
it's again like much of early
Auden, and yet it is a poem that
is secretly very serious.
Well, much of the lightness as
well as the seriousness of the
poem depends on its formal
organization.
These lines are,
well, aren't they about half as
long as a normative line of
poetry?
And they're rhymed,
but they're rhymed in a most
interesting and playful way.
In fact, the poem has a lot of
play in it.
The pleasure that it gives is
one of a certain mild
exhilaration and uncertainty,
of a pattern that includes and
that in fact tolerates,
or even generates,
dramatic change in line length
and surprising rhymes.
The gentleman is,
in a sense, trying to hold
himself together.
The idea is repeated by the
poet trying to hold her lines
together in rhymed couplets.
Bishop is, in general,
a very interesting poet
technically.
Here, as elsewhere,
how relaxed,
how unpretentiously casual,
how disorientingly casual,
even, the voice is!
There isn't here or elsewhere
in Bishop Frost's tension
between speech and meter.
Rather, as in this case,
each keeps getting adjusted to
the other.
It's important;
there's almost no blank verse,
no iambic pentameter in Bishop.
The canonical heroic meter
doesn't appear here,
except, I think,
possibly in one or two
examples.
There are in Bishop free verse
poems.
There's meter and rhyme.
There are often poems that move
in and out of these forms,
much as "The Map" begins in
rhyme, moves out of rhyme,
and returns to rhyme.
The poems don't seek Moore's
highly idiosyncratic crafted
formal arrangements.
Instead, Bishop's practice is
probably closest to Auden's,
who's got a form for every
occasion and a form for every
purpose.
But Auden's forms are always in
a sense pre-set,
drawn from an existing
repertoire.
What is right for this occasion?
A ballad – I will do a
ballad, a sestina,
elegiac quatrains,
et cetera.
That's the way in which Auden
presents himself.
And Auden adheres strictly to
his forms, and he uses those
forms to shape and interpret the
occasions of his writing.
In Bishop's case,
it's really just the other way
around.
What she does is alter her
forms under the pressure of the
occasions of her writing,
her purpose and subject.
Nothing in Bishop is pre-set.
Everything is provisional,
in the process of being remade,
and in the process of constant
readjustment on a technical
level as well as on the
perceptual level that I began by
talking about.
This is a vision really of what
the world is like and how
writing might respond to it.
All of these things are going
on in this little poem,
"The Gentleman of Shallot",
and with a sense of comedy.
If the glass slips
he's in a fix--
only one leg, etc.
But
while it stays put [so long as
we accept this provisional
arrangement]
he can walk and run
and his hands can clasp one
another.
The uncertainty
he says he
finds exhilarating.
He loves [and here's that
phrase from the essay on Eliot]
that sense of constant
re-adjustment.
He wishes to be quoted as
saying at present:
"Half is enough."
A kind of motto that Bishop
might have adopted,
too.
Let's look at another version
of this figure,
this time not a person but a
creature,
and I mean specifically the
sandpiper who appears in a much
later book, Questions of
Travel,
from a book written largely in
the 1950s and early 1960s.
"Sandpiper" is on page 131.
Again, it is a poem that takes
place on the shore.
Instead of the gentleman of
Shalott in his fussy way,
and yet practical way,
getting along in the world,
we are introduced to a finicky
bird:
The roaring alongside he
takes for granted,
and that every so often the
world is bound to shake.
He runs, he runs to the south,
finical, awkward,
in a sense of controlled panic,
a student of Blake.
Another poem that is stationed
on a shifting boundary,
the boundary of the tide.
Bishop is engaged here in a
kind of playful,
active revision of the
visionary innocence celebrated
by William Blake.
I quote the lines on your
handout that Bishop is referring
to:
To see a world in a grain
of sand [this is the beginning
of "Auguries of Innocence"],
And heaven in a wildflower,
Hold infinity in the palm of
your hand,
And eternity in an hour.
Well, here, Bishop is sort of
playfully saying:
well, what kind of figure is
really Blakean?
What kind of figure wants to
see the world in a grain of
sand?
Well, a sandpiper,
looking for his food.
The beach hisses like fat.
On his left, a sheet
of interrupting water comes and
goes
and glazes over his dark and
brittle feet.
He runs, he runs straight
through it, watching his toes.
- Watching, rather [and this is
again Bishop
correcting--proceeding by
correcting her perception],
the spaces of sand between
them,
where (no detail too small)
[and again the sandpiper,
like the poet,
is
focused on detail]
the Atlantic drains
rapidly backwards and downwards.
As he runs,
he stares at the dragging
grains.
The world is a mist.
And then the world is
minute and vast and clear.
The tide
is higher or lower.
He couldn't tell you which.
["North's near as West."]
His beak is focussed;
he is preoccupied,
looking for something,
something, something.
Poor bird, he is obsessed!
The millions of grains are
black, white,
tan, and gray
mixed with quartz grains,
rose and amethyst.
The poem's own structure shifts
interestingly in terms of its
line lengths and Bishop's ways
of using enjambment or
end-stopped lines.
The world is – well,
the place is a world of vast
forces, of roaring,
and of mist,
and yet it's also minute and
clear – all of these things at
once or in succession.
The bird's perspective can't
tell us whether the tide is
higher or lower because he is,
as it were, in the picture:
he's always wherever it is.
It is a position again of
constant readjustment.
What is he looking for?
"Something, something,
something."
A calculatedly vague word,
a word that we see Frost using
in "For Once,
Then, Something."
Instead of moving here towards
generalization,
the poem moves towards more
detail: towards a list,
a series finally of colors,
simply.
In a sense, Bishop moves away
from the black and white to
other shades,
shades that involve
combinations of colors.
The question is really,
how can the world be seen
serially?
How can it be made?
How can it be seen as a series
of perceptions,
and yet be able to cohere?
This is a fundamental question
of Bishop's poetry.
It is, as it were,
the complement of the question:
how can you hold yourself
together?
Well, how can you hold the
world together,
how can you hold the world that
you perceive together?
Bishop's great poem on this
subject is the travel poem,
"Over 2,000 Illustrations and a
Complete Concordance,"
which I promise to talk about
on Monday.